[Musik]
deutschland steht zusammen in einer
schwierigen zeit wir werden als land
durch diese schwierige zeit kommt und
wir haben alle entscheidungen getroffen
die dafür notwendig sind dass wir uns
unterhaken und dass kein bürger und kein
bürger keine bürgerin alleine gelassen
wird dass der bundeskanzler heute
vormittag beim vorstellen des dritten
entlastungspaket und damit guten abend
ihnen allen und willkommen zu einem
ungewöhnlichen nachrichten sonntag die
vom sport hat in etwa 10 minuten norbert
lehmann
mit insgesamt 65 milliarden euro will
die bundesregierung den bürgerinnen und
bürgern unter die arme greifen darauf
haben sich die koalitionsspitzen
geeinigt 65 milliarden die hierzulande
die folgen des russischen angriffskriegs
abfedern sollen wer davon was bekommen
soll zeigt volker dutschek in einem
ersten überblick
auch die rund 21 millionen rentnerinnen
und rentner erhalten jetzt eine
einmalige energiepreis pauschale von 300
euro zum ersten dezember nutznießer auch
studierende 200 euro pro nase
stichwort kindergeld hier bekommen das
erste und zweite kind 18 euro mehr im
monat
beim wohngeld spricht bundeskanzler
scholz von der größten reform seit
langem die zahl der berechtigten wächst
von 700.000 auf zwei millionen für jeden
single haushalt einmalig 415 euro
heizkostenzuschuss für paare 540 euro
100 euro für jedes weitere
haushaltsmitglied
das neue bürgergeld löste im januar die
alten hartz 4 regelung ab die regelsätze
werden auf rund 500 euro angehoben das
viel gewünschte bundesweite nahverkehrs
ticket soll kommen ein datum noch unklar
der bund gibt jährlich 1,5 milliarden
euro noch einmal die gleiche summe
sollen die länder beisteuern
auch die kalte progression nimmt die
bundesregierung ins visier sie will 48
millionen arbeitnehmer durch korrekturen
bei den einkommen steuertarifen
entlasten die bundesregierung verspricht
eine strompreis bremse für
privathaushalte
demnach soll ein vergünstigter preis für
ein gewissen basis verbrauchern strom
gelten für den verbrauch darüber hinaus
wäre der preis nicht begrenzt
sozialverbände wie caritas und diakonie
werten das entlastungspaket als
wichtigen baustein für sozialen frieden
industrie und handwerk bemängeln zu
wenig hilfe für unternehmen
wirtschaftswissenschaftler loben die
gezielte unterstützung von besonders
belasteten gruppen kritisieren aber dass
einiges noch zu unkonkret sei britta
spiekermann über die regierungspläne und
reaktionen darauf
22 stunden beratungen am ende ein
gemeinsames papier wie es heißt ein
wuchtiges entlastungspaket die ampel
koalitionäre scheinen zufrieden mit sich
und ihren ergebnissen jetzt sollen auch
von der krise profitieren die
energiekonzerne zur kasse gebeten werden
wir haben deshalb fest vor erinnerung
dass wir die marktordnung zu ändern dass
diese zufalls gewinne nicht mehr
anfallen oder dass sie abgeschöpft
werden sollte das auf europäischer ebene
nicht zügig klappen werde es einen
nationalen alleingang geben trotz
gewaltiger gesamtausgaben versichert
finanzminister lindner die
schuldenbremse könne wie geplant
nächstes jahr wieder greifen man
haushalte sorgsam wir
stärken die menschen die unsere
solidarität brauchen und vergessen
diejenigen nicht auf deren schultern
dieses land steht nämlich die hart
arbeitende mitte es soll ein
entschlossenes signal gesendet werden
nach innen und nach außen wir werden uns
nicht spalten lassen in diesem land
nicht von der russischen aggression in
der ukraine und nicht von der russischen
art und von der aggressiven art und
weise wie russland die energie in diesem
land versucht zu verknappen und damit
auch die preise an treibt die union lobt
das auch studierende rentnerinnen und
rentner entlastet werden beklagt aber
mangelnde hilfen für unternehmen und
sieht eine entscheidende lücke sie haben
im grunde genommen diesen angebotsschock
den wir haben durch das ausbleiben der
russische gas überhaupt nicht
angesprochen geschweige denn kompensiert
wir haben konkret vorgeschlagen jetzt
auf alle energiequellen zurückzugreifen
die zur verfügung stehen also auch auf
die atomenergie die afg hingegen sieht
eine andere baustelle kritisiert den
plan über gewinne abzuschöpfen wie will
man feststellen wer über gewinn gemacht
hat man greift hier als bundesregierung
in die marktwirtschaft ein was wir
grundsätzlich ablehnen die ampel will
also weiter entlasten und große
energiekonzerne in die pflicht nehmen
noch steht aber alles nur auf dem papier
fragen wer stark unter ben ali in berlin
ist das jetzt der große wurf der
versprochen war
ja das ist noch nicht ausgemacht denn
die einigung unter den
koalitionspartnern ist ja nur der erste
schritt da steht jetzt eben dieses große
ziel 65 milliarden und eine sehr lange
liste von maßnahmen auf dem papier aber
zur umsetzung braucht es eben mehr an
manchen stellen als die bundesregierung
und den willen der bundesregierung
alleine beim neuen euro ticket etwa
müssen bei dem nachfolge des 99 euro
tickets müssen 16 bundesländer mit
überzeugt werden und bei einem
kernelement der abschöpfung und der
umverteilung der zufalls gewinne wie ist
die bundesregierung jetzt nennt ist erst
einmal europa am zug und dann erst auf
nationaler ebene die frage ob man und
wie man ist dann umsetzt also damit es
wirklich der ganz große wurf wird müssen
diese unbekannten in der rechnung dann
auch auf gehen nur dann kann es gelingen
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
schack unterleib energy
fordern bezahlten für den bundeskanzler
olaf scholz muss das land durch eine der
schlimmsten krisen führen und die
unzufriedenheit mit seiner arbeit wächst
ein thema beim zdf sommerinterview
andreas cüppers berichtet
nach zehn monaten im amt bei seinem
ersten sommerinterview als bundeskanzler
ist das ansehen von olaf scholz auf
seine bisherigen tiefs punkte gesunken
für scholz kein maßstab er antwortet das
ist meine verantwortung ist dafür zu
sorgen dass wir entschiedene handlungen
machen und dass wir sehr besonnen
handeln und ich ertrage dass das
unsere skeptisch betrachten aber ich
habe einen eid geschworen und für diesen
alt ich arbeite tag und markt die
bezeichnung zögerlich lässt scholz für
sich nicht gelten die deutschen
waffenlieferungen etwa seien mit den
verbündeten abgestimmt eine antwort auch
an den ukrainischen premier schmid der
scholz am nachmittag darum bittet die
hilfe für sein land zu verstärken
und so sind alle entscheidungen gut
abgewogen und das will ich ausdrücklich
sagen dazu stehe ich es wird keine
deutschen alleingänge geben dass scholz
mitte august schweigt als
palästinenserpräsident abbas neben ihm
holocaust vorwürfe
gegen israel erhebt sei kein fehler
gewesen er habe ja später deutlich
reagiert das habe ich scharf kritisiert
und ich habe da für viele sehr wichtige
rückmeldungen gute rückmeldung aus
israel bekommen aber ich bin ganz klar
sagen wir sind in einer zeit in der
viele sehr aufgeregt sind und ich zähle
nicht zu diesen und will es auch nicht
sein keine kritik keine selbstkritik
keine zweifel für olaf scholz ist olaf
scholz auf dem richtigen weg
das ganze interview mit dem
bundeskanzler sehen sie direkt nach uns
und sämtliche details des
entlastungspaket finden sie auch bei zdf
heute und in der app in berlin gab es
heute neben wichtigen entscheidungen
auch hochrangigen besuch vom
israelischen staatspräsidenten herzog
mit militärischen ehren empfehlen ihnen
bundespräsident steinmeier auf schloss
bellevue dabei würdigten beide die
einigung im streit über entschädigungen
wegen des olympia attentats 72 morgen
wollen sie an der gedenkfeier in münchen
teilnehmen
die bundesregierung will mehr gegen den
fachkräftemangel tun arbeitsminister
heil kündigte in der bild am sonntag ein
einwanderungsgesetz an dass eine so
genannte chancen karte vorsieht eine
bestimmte anzahl von zuwanderern könnte
dann problemlos in deutschland arbeiten
vorausgesetzt der lebensunterhalt wird
selbst bestritten
im harz gilt seit heute der
katastrophenfall bereits zum zweiten mal
innerhalb eines monats wütet ein
waldbrand am brocken das feuer breitete
sich nach angaben der behörden in der
nacht aus und ist noch immer nicht unter
kontrolle
rund 300 einsatzkräfte kämpfen gegen die
flammen wanderer und besucher mussten in
sicherheit gebracht werden
und jetzt zur basketball heim em da hat
die deutsche national ist
nationalmannschaft einen lauf ja das
kann man wohl sagen drittes spiel
dritter sieg aber diesmal war es so was
von knapp und vor allem so was von
spannend erst nach zweimaliger
verlängerung bezwangen das dbb-team
litauer mit 100 92 107 ja und steht
vorzeitig in der endrunde
nach fast zweieinhalb stunden ende
dieses epische duell das auf deutscher
seite maßgeblich von den beiden nba
spieler nenne schröder und franz wagner
geprägt wird die zusammen mehr als die
hälfte der punkte erzielen ein klares
zeichen für den tollen teamgeist ist es
aber dass die partie in köln von dem
berliner modulo mit 23 jahren in der
zweiten verlängerung entschieden wird
deutschland damit in der endrunde aber
noch unter vorbehalt denn litauen hat
wegen eines formalen schiedsrichter
fehlers protest eingelegt
[Applaus]
auslosung der zweiten runde im dfb-pokal
vorhin live bei uns in der sportstudio
reportage und hier die interessantesten
begegnungen
fünftligist stuttgarter kickers empfängt
frankfurt regionalligisten lübeck die
mainzer leverkusen-bezwinger und
drittligist elversberg trifft auf bochum
titelverteidiger leipzig gegen den hsv
pokalfinalist freiburg gegen pauli
hoffenheim trifft auf schalke augsburg
auf münchen und stuttgart auf bielefeld
und
im ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga gewinnt die hertha in
augsburg mit 2 zu 0 die berliner auf auf
den 13 tabellenplatz der fc runter auf
rang 16 formel 1 weltmeister max
verstappen hat den großen preis der
niederlande geworden der red bull pilot
siegte wie im vorjahr bei seinem heim
spiel ins antwort vor mercedes mann
george russel und charly claire ferrari
fährst als zehnter saisonsieg
und zum tennis und zu den us open hat
jude niemeyer auch ihr drittes spiel
gewonnen die 23 jährige dortmunderin
setzte sich mit einem 6 zu 4 7 5-erfolg
gegen die chinesin jing quinn durch und
zog als einzig verbliebene deutsche
einzelspielerin ins achtelfinale ein und
dort trifft sie auf die
weltranglisten-erste egal sonntag aus
polen
das wassersport dankeschön wir schauen
noch aufs wetter morgen ist es im norden
und osten wolkig schauer bleiben aber
die ausnahme
sonst gibt es viel sonne 21 grad an der
ostsee 32 am rhein
in den nächsten tagen gibt es teils
kräftigen regen und gewitter und es wird
spürbar kühler im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn spricht christian
sievers mit finanzministern lindner wer
seinen chips bis morgen wünschen ihnen
einen guten start in die neue woche und
empfehlen jetzt das doch mal interview
mit dem bundeskanzler